investir mec j'ai décidé de filmer
le mariage de mon frère
Rod ne reste pas là ce que tu es dans
le magasin elle l'a fouillée jusqu'à ton école
avec cette arme blanche s'est avérée ils
m'ont réduit comme un champ de drogue
découvrons à quel point le  les vieux
mariés savent l'un sur l'autre quelle est la
chose la plus embarrassante qui se soit produite
pendant les rapports sexuels
maintenant nous mettons des poids dans le bouquet
et cela éliminera les bagues lors d'un
grand jour donc le moment spécial où vous
m'avez demandé de voyager dans une Rolls Royce oui bien
oui alors tu changes tu veux
toujours voyager dans un grand rendez-vous ne veux-tu pas
à Champlin je suis juste une mère qui veut que
le jour du mariage de sa fille soit spécial
êtes-vous tous les deux vierges
la compétence du planificateur est de rester une
piscine  de calme Oh comment as-tu bien géré ça,
je ne m'en souviens pas, mais les ponceaux
vont bien tant que tu ne les mélanges pas avec de l'
alcool
tu cherches du vin pour avoir un
incroyable
106 c'est un mariage et tu le traites comme si
c'était  une partie je suis malheureux s  o vraiment
c'est juste un mariage et le tout
je veux juste que tu sois heureux
Je prends au sérieux car j'ai jamais pris
quoi que ce soit désolé dis-tu que les
muscles verts meurent
maintenant tu ne peux pas t'appeler un vrai
chasseur de pop  le vieil homme soit les Tigres
maintenant Oh